deschacht panthères
lorsqu'on étudie l'histoire du panzer 5
plus communément appelée panthère est
souvent présenté comme le meilleur char
moyen d'un seconde guerre mondiale il
faut aussi en examiner les conséquences
sur l'armée allemand et en particulier
son arme blindés au moment où hitler
décide de lancer la wehrmacht
sur le front de l'est contre l'union
soviétique le 22 juin 1941 3 heures du
matin l'horizon de la côte de la
baltique jusqu'aux contreforts des
carpates fut éliminé par des tirs de
plus de 6000 canons d'artillerie
préparatoire à l'opération barbarossa
l'invasion par l'allemagne de l'union
soviétique
ce fut la plus grande offensive
terrestre de tous les temps
3 millions d'hommes avec 3350 chars
appuyés par plus de 2000 avions de la
luftwaffe franchir la frontière en un
blitzkrieg éprouvée dont hitler espérer
une victoire rapide
la bataille n'étant pas censé durer plus
de quelques mois
le dictateur de l'allemagne nazie
regardait en effet l'urss avec
condescendance n'ayant son image de
nation puissante
nous n'aurons qu'à enfoncer la porte et
tout le reste effondrera comme un
château de cartes et met il à dire tous
ces préjugés basé sur sa pensée
antisémite anti marxiste ouvertement
raciste qui réalisait les slaves les
russes au rang de sous-hommes dans la
vision d'asie corroborait l'analyse des
renseignements allemands sur l'économie
militaire soviétique qui se trouvait
profondément miné
oh
cette analyse qui servit de son man
l'opération barbarossa était finalement
plus remarquable parce que le disait pas
sur ce nouvel ennemi que parce qu'elles
ont montré comme le nombre d'avions et
déchirant servi dans l'armée où je
n'étais pas connu sera annoncée alors
n'étaient que de simples estimations les
allemands savaient peu de choses sur
l'ordre de bataille soviétique ou sur
l'organisation des tailles et des unités
russes il ne savait rien des profonds
changements d'industrie soviétique issus
du plan quinquennal et encore moins sur
la capacité russes arméniens
d'engagement dans la durée en bref
l'armée allemande s'est engagée dans un
conflit avec l'urss sur la simple
conviction que cette dernière ne serait
pas en mesure de supporter un pompier
moderne et de faire face à la plus
efficace machine de guerre jamais créé
et tout ce qui arriva dans les premiers
mois de la campagne semblé donner raison
d'état major allemand au sujet de
l'armée rouge et de la situation de
l'état soviétique sans le savoir exacte
et au pire moment pour les soviétiques
non seulement l'armée rouge se remettait
à peine des purges qui avait décimé son
corps d'officiers mais également de
l'umih nation suivi précédemment face à
la finlande
en juin 1941 elle opérait une profonde
restructuration ainsi qu'un gigantesque
programme d'équipement
alors que les colonnes de penseurs foncé
à travers les défenses soviétique pour
s'enfoncer loin dans l'arrière-pays et
encerclé des centaines de milliers de
soldats russes dans les premières
semaines de la campagne
de nombreux signes amenèrent les
allemands se rendre compte que cette
nouvelle campagne dans l'est n'allait
pas se passer comme les autres campagnes
un officier d'un 17e panzerdivision
écrivit nous n'avions pas le sentiment
comme cela s'était produit en france
d'entrer dans un pays vaincu
à la place nous rencontrions de la
résistance toujours de la résistance
même s'il était sans espoir bien
évidemment même hitler disait mussolini
qui soldats russes se battait avec un
fanatisme stupide et la brutalité
primaire de l'animal qui se sent pris au
piège bien que le führer n'y voyait que
la confirmation que les soviétiques
étaient des sous-hommes
il ne pouvait tout de même pas manqué de
constater que ces sous-hommes avait déjà
tué plus de cent mille soldats allemands
dans les premières semaines de
l'opération barbarossa c'est à dire plus
que lors de toutes les campagnes
précédentes réunies
pas plus que les allemands n'ignorait
que les divisions soviétiques étaient
apparemment inépuisable puisque elle
revenait toujours plus nombreuses à
chaque fois que les allemands les
détruisez fin juillet les allemands
avaient déjà recensé plus de divisions
de l'armée rouge qui ne l'avait jamais
su poser les russes était prolifique en
termes de ressources humaines
mais face à la rapidité de la vence
allemande et leur impréparation à
contrer le bitz craig
elles durent céder du terrain et des
hommes pour gagner du temps des
centaines de milliers de soldats russes
sur ainsi fait prisonnier plus tard un
soldat allemand racontera un vrai
crocodile bras avancer lentement face à
nous c'était des prisonniers de guerre
russe par rangée de 6 n'arrivions pas à
distinguer la fin de la colonne à mesure
qu'il se rapprochait la puanteur
épouvantable qui venait à nous nous
donna presque la nausée
nous nous sommes rapidement éloigné du
nuage malodorants qui les entouraient
puis ce que nos vies nous clouer sur
place et nous fait oublier notre know et
ses hommes au visage gris brun saison
bras du ciné qui trébuche et il semblait
rendre leur dernier souffle
était il encore des êtres humains ou
bien des créatures à qui seule une
petite flamme de volonté avait encore
permis d'obéir à l'ordre de marche
le 16 juillet moins d'un mois après le
lancement de barbaros à la ville de
smolensk à peine 300 km au sud de moscou
touba aux mains des penseurs d'europe et
du goût derrière dans leur marche vers
l'est les blindés allemands avaient
détruit un grand nombre de chars
soviétiques go derian avait estimé avant
la campagne que l'armée rouge devrait
disposer d'environ 10000 anges et ce fut
cette estimation qui en compte par
l'armée évidemment il devient vite clair
que cette estimation était fausse et que
la réalité se situait plutôt aux
alentours de 30 milliards et leur
signifier à plus tard a good ariane que
s'il avait eu le chiffrement de la
planification de la campagne il aurait
reconsidéré sérieusement sa décision
d'envahir la russie bien que le nombre
garantissent pas la qualité que la
majorité des matériels équipant l'armée
rouge fait obsolète
la majorité de ces engins daté du début
des années 30 la plupart du temps basé
sur des concepts étrangers
ce que les témoignages montrent le plus
souvent sont des carcasses en flammes de
tvh insisté 28 et 30,7 et des chars
légers de la série bt pas simple avec
canon supérieur à 45 mm et tous
n'avaient qu'un faible blindage le tube
de 50 mm à canon court du panshir 3 et
le 75 minutes cours du penseur cap
n'avait aucune difficulté pour détruire
ses chats et l'estrie vie ici montre un
grand nombre de ces chars détruits est
en feu
même le canon de 20 mm du panzer 2 est
le 37 millimètres du panshir 38 et
affronter ces engins sans problème et
même la présidente et 35 le char multi
turrel vu ici est très très vulnérable
face aux obus allemands
mais au milieu de toute cette
obsolescence un certain nombre de
nouvelles machines tenait la dragée
haute aux penseurs avec les cavs et 1 et
qu'avait 2 les soviétiques disposer de
deux chats technologiquement supérieurs
à n'importe quel char alban avec un
blindage aussi épais que celui du mat
ida britannique et un armement lourd tel
que le 76 mm du kavé 1a le biais de 52
sur le kavé 2
ces deux engins t2 redoutable machine
les obus allemands glissé sur le
blindage de ces deux monstres mais ce
fut le thé 34 qui fit la plus grosse
impression rapide
pesant seulement 26 tonnes avec un
blindage ep incliné et en portant un
canon de 76 mm il apparut comme une
révélation tankiste allemand
heureusement pour eux ils n'étaient pas
disponibles en grand nombre étaient mal
employé le tfca de vue ici l'un des
premiers modèles produits en 1940
comme en france à ce char britanniques
et français lourdement blindés le canon
de 88 mm se révéla apte à affronter les
nouveaux chars soviétiques
et
l'infanterie allemande trouve à d'autres
méthodes pour détruire les t34 et qu'un
virus des charges étaient placés sur les
angevins soviétique
bien que cela demandait beaucoup de
sang-froid soldats qui courait vers le
char proposer sa charge sur le bloc
moteur ou à la base de la tourelle de
telles méthodes étaient seulement
employés lorsqu'ils ne disposait pas un
bon canons antichars
le canon 37 minutes se montra inutile
tant sa munition était incapable de
percer le blindage des chars russes
ce fut seulement lors de l'opération qui
font l'offensive allemande visant la
prise de moscou fin septembre 41 que le
thé 34 devant une réelle menace pour les
penseurs avec l'arrivée de la race
footix à la période des puits avant
l'arrivée de l'hiver qui transforma les
routes russes en bourbier les penseurs
allemands sanguinaire du fait de leurs
chemises et 3 alors que les 34 lui avait
été étudié spécialement pour opérer en
conditions difficiles
am 5 le 4 octobre
les petits 34 père pour la première fois
en grand nombre infligeant de lourdes
pertes pensèrent 3 dans la quatrième
panzer division plus tard goûter rien
commente à la bataille de cinq ans la
décrivant comme la première fois au
cours de laquelle la nette supériorité
du thé 34 apparu pleinement aux
allemands
lorsque typhon se transforma finalement
en une gigantesque halte début décembre
un grand nombre de tes 34 appartenant
des divisions fraîche et entraîné en
sibérie var contrer l'offensive
allemande sur moscou le 5 décembre 1941
il apparaît alors clairement l'armée
allemande qu'elle allait devoir procéder
par étapes pour faire face à l'évidente
supériorité technologique les russes
posséder avec le thé 34
là
en octobre 1941
les membres de la commission de l'armé
blindée rencontrèrent le général but
dérian à orelle en russie pour étudier
une réponse adaptée à la menace du thé
34 en plus du développement du futur
chars lourds tigre décision fut prise de
lancer la production d'un char moyens
sous la désignation de veka 3002 dont
les contrats furent signés dans les
jours qui suivirent le retour de la
commission en allemagne le démonstrateur
de daimler benz initialement favori
reflétait clairement l'influencent du
thé 34 avec son lourd blindage incliné
et sa tourelle montée très en avant du
châssis le 15 mai 1942 hitler se
rangeant aux recommandations d'un
rapport qui favorise l adoption de
l'alternative proposée par man le
prototype du panthères présentait de
nombreux changements nécessité par
développement de ce nouveau char le
poids avait grimpé à 45 tonnes et le
cheikh était maintenant armé d'un
formidable tubes elles 70 de 75 mm à
canon long les contrats furent signés en
septembre 1942 pour un total de 1000
charpente r les premiers temps livrable
en janvier 1943 des lignes de production
furent montés en parallèle chez daimler
benz mnhn seul à castle
on ne se souciait guère qu'à panthères
sont apparus brièvement juste derrière à
tigres filmés au premier plan lors d'un
journal d actualité en 1943 le nouveau
panthère est une période de gestation
très courte des planches à dessin aux
chaînes de production il s'écroula tout
juste un an
les allemands étaient très optimiste à
l'idée que ce nouveau chardonne à la
panthère valff la supériorité
technologique qui lui avait fait tant
défaut le premier panthères fait un
modèle d reconnaissable à la coupole du
chef de char ainsi qu'aux rabat sur le
poste de mitrailleur du côté gauche de
la tourelle par d'autres aspects comme
l'épaisseur du blindage tous les modèles
étaient identiques 80 mm de blindage
seul des six avants 120 mm pour le
masque du canon et 40 mm sur les côtés
le premier modèle à comportait une
coupole moulay disposant de sept
périscope les panthères à suivant était
équipé d'un apu sur bull monte sur le
glacis pour la mitrailleuse à partir de
seul le modèle g à être produit jusqu'à
la fin de la guerre le baptême du feu du
panthéon eu lieu avec l'opération
citadelle envoie 43 qui ne fut pas une
bonne idée
cette dernière offensive sur le front de
l'est devaient être de courte durée et
sur une zone géographique restreinte
mais compte tenu du nombre de chars et
des troupes aligner ce fut un engagement
majeur de ressources pourtant devenu
rare au moment où le spectre de la
guerre s'élargissait dramatiquement
pourtant c'était en partie pour résoudre
ce dilemme que citadel fut lancée le but
de cette opération était de détruire les
forces motorisés soviétique à coux ainsi
que les nombreuses troupes massées dans
cette région raccourcissant ainsi la
ligne de front et désengageant les
panzer division pour les envoyer à
l'ouest dans la tente d'un débarquement
en france à l'origine prévu pour le
printemps l'opération citadelle suis
sans cesse repoussée pour pouvoir
engager un nombre suffisant canon
ferdinand et de char tiré panthères il
t'a pensaient que leur seule présence en
nombre lui assurerait une issue
favorable pour cette opération
aucune image n'existe des 200 plantaire
engagés dans l'offensive organisé en
deux bataillons de chars les 51 et 52 et
sous le commandement du major vent l'urt
le régiment de panthère et est rattachée
à la division grosse deutschland
lors de l'opération citadelle sur le
papier il s'agissait de la plus
puissante unité blindée présenta course
mais son efficacité fut sérieusement
amoindrie par son engagement prématurée
dans la bataille bien qu'ayant été créé
début 43 les deux bataillons
rencontrèrent tant de problèmes avec
leur panthères que la majorité d'entre
eux je renvoyais en usine pour y être
révisée ou reconstruits goerrian alors
inspecteur général de l'armée blindée
allemande avait baptisé le panthères
notre enfant difficile tant ça
maintenant c'était un cauchemar
fruit d'un développement et d'une
construction trop hâtif même les
équipages n'avait pas à l'entraînement
suffisant sur leur nouvelle machine
cinq jours après le début de l'offensive
il ne restait plus que 10 panthères
opérationnel 25 avaient été détruits et
s'en était hors service
bien que le blindage frontale et fait
ses preuves les 45 mm de blindage
latéral s'était montré trop vulnérables
face aux canons anti chars russes
beaucoup de panthère ayant été perdu de
cette manière
malgré tout le cas l'an 60 15 mm s'était
montré très efficace détruisant le thé
34 à 3000 m
alors que la cadence de production
augmentait d'autres bataillons de
panthère a été mis sur pied envoyé
hâtivement combat pour contrer la montée
en puissance de l'armée rouge qui est en
reprise sativa course était quelques
mois après la bataille en train de
repousser les allemands vers la partie
sud du front
en octobre il y avait cinq bataillons de
verre marc et des ss doté de panthère
engagés dans la bataille
et tandis qu'en novembre d'autres
affluaient en continu le rythme effréné
des opérations et les problèmes
techniques ininterrompue occasioner de
lourdes pertes et sur un total de 843
panthères déployés sur le front de l'est
en 1943 seuls 80 des 217 encore
disponible le 31 décembre bien 143 était
réellement opérationnels plus de 620 4
machines ayant été perdus il fallut
attendre mars 44 pour que geri ans
déclare le panthères parfaitement
opérationnels
durant l'hiver 43-44 l'armée rouge la
seule série d'opérations coup de poing
contre le groupement sud où les lignes
allemandes est fréquemment traverser les
peintures du visiom ce jouet pour ainsi
dire le rôle de pompier de combats font
sens d'une brèche à l'autre pour tenter
de contrer chaque percée soviétique
des groupes de combat âpre aux visées
composé d'éléments issus d'unités
diverses avec tous les appuis
nécessaires étaient souvent créées pour
faire face à de telles éventualités
l'un d'eux était le pense de régiments
de becker dont les 47 panthère et 34
tigre constitué l'épiné dorsale du
colonne rassemblés depuis février 44
pour créer un corridor par lequel devait
s'échapper soixante mille soldats
allemands encerclé près de tcherkassy à
la mi mars 44 4 e division d'infanterie
soviétique appuyé par un grand nombre de
chars encerclaient le groupement
commandé par le ss gruppen fourrure
herbert jill dans la ville de cauvel un
important noeud de voies ferroviaires de
la russie européenne d'une grande
importance stratégique pour les deux
camps une force de dégagement fut mise
sur pied par les allemands comportant
notamment des éléments de la 4e porte
sur division' avec en tête une compagnie
de panthère de la 5e ss panzer division
vikings commandé par l'auberge from
fourrure nikoloz il est mais là tu as
calme en tueur ramé par le sol maraka
jeu de cette zone qui constituait un
excellent terrain défensif pour les
soviétiques
le seul passage fermes possibles pour
les panthères était le remblai de la
voie ferrée qui menait à covè lé 30 mars
à 4 heures du matin nicolosi lait cuit
avancer ses troupes le long du remblai
avec neuf en terre mais ont perdu aussi
conne deux à cause des mines
celle ci refuse neutralisé par
l'infanterie mais les panthères ne
purent rentrer dans la vie avant le
crépuscule pour relever les défenseurs
beaucoup de panthère dont le panthères
de commandement reconnaissable à son
antenne supplémentaire montés sur le
toit de la caisse furent abandonnés le
long de la voie ferrée détruits par des
mines ou par les tirs anti chars
soviétiques après la bataille les halles
vont se servir des prisonniers de guerre
soviétiques pour aller récupérer les
panthères endommagés dont la plupart fut
réparée et retourner au combat
les corps des équipages tuer qui avait
été ensevelie à la va vite dans le sable
du ballast sur a6 récupérer
les troupes stationnées à coven furent
est finalement récupéré le sac avril
pour une autre attaque impliquant les
panzers 4 et des canons d'un troisième
panzer des visionnent de concert avec
des panthères de la division vikings il
effectuerait une percée dans les lignes
de défense soviétique pourtant solide au
nord de la ville par la route cauvel
bref titoff les positions anti charges
réduites et les chars soviétiques parmi
lesquels des sherman américains obtenus
grâce au régime du prédame furent
détruits lors de l'avancée en ville
fin août 1944 offensif d'été des
soviétiques avait tout détruit sauf le
groupement centre et amener l'armée
rouge à la frontière polonaise
c'est dans cette région qu une équipe de
propagande film à des combats de chars
lors que les allemands tentaient
désespérément de stopper l'avancée vers
l'ouest
à ce stade de la guerre les waffen ss
était sous le feu de la rampe et à cette
occasion l'équipe de tournage s'était
concentrée sur une contre attaque menée
par la 5e ss panzer division de viking
sous les ors du schumann sur un maillot
dressent des panthères à pied par des
penseurs quatre avaient attaqué des
unités soviétique l'équipe et de thé
34,85 js2 qui a occupé de nombreux
villages alentour des automoteurs vsp
hummel ouvrir le feu sur les positions
soviétique les panther profitèrent de
leur vitesse pour avancer rapidement
d'une position de tir à une autre et se
rapprocher de la cible
les grenadiers suivait de près dans
leurs semis chenilles et blindés t'es
engagé l'infanterie soviétique sur leurs
positions avancées
les panthères attaquer les blindés
soviétiques tandis que grenadiers
pourchasse d'inventrices olic réfugier
dans les champs de maïs
alors que l'infanterie avant ce à
travers les premiers campements en feu
le ac ce groupe une forge il à la tête
de la 4e ss panzer division qui porte
son nom à plat rapidement pour
déterminer les objectifs suivants de
l'attak un détachement de reconnaissance
ur folgen schwimmwagen et semi chenier
sdk et vii 10,6 mouvement pour dégager
le terrain en avant de la fente rient et
se déployer à travers les larges champs
de blé de maïs les semis chenille
suivent la vence des panthères qui
évolue à travers ses chants a découvert
voici la mesure du rôle secondaire joué
par l'aviation sur le front de l'est où
les blindés allemands continuent
d'opérer sous un ciel vide de tout avion
russe alors qu'en normandie
une telle opération est forcement t à
l'attention des chasseurs bombardiers
alliés
le détachement des divisions vikings
doom le fait mouvement et ouvrent le feu
sur une autre position soviétique à
l'aise de ses canons de 150 mm les chefs
de chars des panthères observons
maintenant le prochain village paisible
et passer à l'action
ensuite ils ouvrent le feu et les
grenadines la viking qui investissent le
village trouvaient un grand nombre de
tes 34,85 js2 en feu ce dernier était un
charlot introduit au printemps 44 100
canons 222 millièmes est l'une des armes
qu'ils pouvaient facilement perforé le
glacis frontale la panthère mais la
vitesse initiale très individuelle 71 75
mm permettait à celui ci le toucher du
premier coup et de perforer la tourelle
du char soviétique avis 100 m comme
cette distance reste à la portée du
temps cru ce sont d'autres paramètres
tels que l'entraînement la qualité des
optiques allemande et les procédures de
commandement qui explique les résultats
vue sur ces images
malgré les pertes infligées aux
soviétiques par les blindés allemands
elle n'était jamais suffisante face au
raz-de-marée d'engins qui sortait des
chaînes de production pour les remplacer
et
plus au nord la troisième armée qui
avait dû repousser en lettonie en
lituanie par les premier deuxième front
baltique livré un rude combat défensif
les bataillons de panthère se bâtir aux
côtés des compagnies thing ces images
montrent même une paire de penseurs
trois et quatre survivants
le peu de contre attaques réalisées par
ces unités bien que réussie n'eurent pas
d' influence sur le bilan général
la pression se vit dix continuent à
augmenter en quelques semaines la
troisièmpe answer se retrouve en train
de se battre en prusse orientale avec la
cesam armée de terré dans la région de
la courlande
au cours de toutes les batailles menées
par les équipages de panthère il dit
avoir de multiples occasions pour les
tankistes de faire ce que font ceux ci
remercier leur bonne étoile et les
ouvriers de krups pour l'efficacité de
leur blindage le 6 juin 1944 l'invasion
de l'europe tant attendu arrive enfin
avec le débarquement de normandie
virtuellement sans résistance sous une
couverture aérienne massive les alliés
avaient réussi à faire des marques et
150 mille hommes et 500 chars la fin du
premier jour
l'insistance d'euros mal quand au fait
qu un débarquement ne pourrait être
vaincue que sur les plages s'évapore
avec l'absence de toute unité de
penseurs à proximité de normandie ceci
fut la conséquence d'un désaccord du
haut commandement
quant à la position sur laquelle rugby
station une pompe sert à l'ouest de même
que celle de l'idée qu'un débarquement
allié aurait forcément lieu dans le pas
de calais même après le 6 juin la
désinformation alliés continuent à de
convaincre les allemands qu'un autre
débarquement allait avoir lieu dans
cette région
juste avant le jour j l'aviation sans
faille à paralyser des communications
allemande alors que la lutte soit feu
étaient absents officiel de france pour
un moment
une fois sur les côtes la première tâche
des alliés fut de renforcer leur tête de
compte pour acheminer plus de troupes et
de matériel depuis l'angleterre afin
d'être aussi fort que possible
lorsqu'un livrer les inévitables
renforts allemands les attaques allemand
du 6 juin avec et sporadiques
la 21e point de sa division s'était
opposé au débarquement canadiens
britanniques et s'y était cassé les
dents le lendemain la deuxième
ss panzer division bleue qu'il avance
canadienne sur caen qui était prévu pour
être pris le jour même du débarquement
au final la bataille de caen devait
déboucher sur la bataille de normandie
alors que les alliés s'enfonçait à
l'intérieur des terres il sort très
rapidement un problème insoluble pour
lequel rien ou si peu avait été pensé
autant les plages du débarquement de
normandie avait été choisi par leur
praticabilité autant la campagne
environnante et est idéal pour la
défense des centaines de petits champs
séparés depuis des siècles par des eaux
six autres cas pénétrable ponctuée de
taille et de forêts
connu sous le nom de bocage normand ans
d extrêmement difficile la progression
vers à nummi décidé à ne pas se laisser
faire
la campagne aérienne alliée destinée à
bloquer les mouvements des renforts
allemands en route pour la normandie
durant toute la journée tout
spécialement les unités de
reconnaissance des panzer division n'est
pas mieux illustré que par exemple la
peinture l'air division cette unité
blindée l'une des plus puissants prison
enfants étaient chargés de rejoindre
caen le 6 juin avant la tombée de la
nuit
du fait des bombardements alliés
n'arrive à sion parce que lui et ne fut
rassemblé que l'on du jour suivant
cette expérience oblige les divisions se
déplacer la nuit et à se cacher dans la
forêt le jour cette utilisation
intensive de la force aérienne eu pour
conséquence la destruction de nombreux
villages et habitation proche des champs
de bataille de normandie avec le tigre
le panthéon était l'un des chars les
plus puissants de tous les théâtres et
puis de 481 quatre exemplaires furent
déployés entre géants juillet en théorie
le 1er bataillon de chaque régiment
blindé devait être neutre de panthère
mais je ne suis pas le cas seuls sept
régiments sur dix étaient ainsi équipés
et la majorité appartenait à la waffen
ss
le gros des panthères en normandie
étaient des modèles à avec un plus petit
nombre de modèles g et quelques d
les alliés après rapidement à craindre
le panthères bien qu'elle tire un obus
plus léger que le 80 mm du tigre sont
extrêmes vitesse initiale du fer métiers
de l'it et détruire n'importe quelle
blindés allié à longue distance les
charmes and gamble et churchill faisait
des cibles faciles à 900 mètres la
vulnérabilité de ces chars face aux
panthères et aux tigres devant presque
un scandale politique au royaume uni le
maréchal montgomery dû intervenir pour
assurer que la menace représentée par
les chars allemands était surfaite et
que les charrs alice acte est fort bien
de la mission qui leur est dévolue
bien qu'une telle version des faits
était acceptable pour l'opinion publique
les équipages de chars demeurait
sceptique beaucoup et qui perdent leurs
engins de blindage additionnel sur la
forme de plaques d'acier soudées
on est par ailleurs découvert que le
panthères peut être détruit avec un thé
rapprocher sous laon base du canon le
but 1 6-2 very cocher sur le canon
franchi pénétrer le toit de la caisse au
dessus du pilote et du mitrailleur les
tankistes américain découvert également
qu'un doublé ricochant sur le sol
pouvait pénétrer le bas de caisse
mais ces méthodes imposées équipage à
lille de s'approcher largement cela
limite de portée du cadre du plan terre
ce qui demandait beaucoup de courage
pour tenter le coup
seul sherman faire flat une amélioration
réalisé par les britanniques qui
remplacèrent le canon de 75 cours par
une version modifiée de leurs canons
antichars de 17 livres de nos alliés a
shark capable de perforer les 80 mm de
blindage du panthères aux distances de
combat les femmes furent affectés au
sein de chaque pôle auto en raison de 1
pour quatre chars bien entendu les chefs
de chars de panthère chercher à engager
les fire faille en premier dans tous les
combats
le long canon 17 livres était le seul
indice qui leur permettait d identifier
les tankistes aliette entière du reste
souvent de les camoufler pour les rendre
moins visible mais firefly certes
efficace pour détruire les panthères
comme le montrent ces images d'un modèle
a détruit dans la vallée de l'aude ont
jusqu'à l'arrivée du 1 26 américains
sont canons de 90 mm juste avant la fin
de la guerre le fin effet resté le seul
char capables de défaire les panthères
allemand
même les panthères ne pouvait résister à
l'incroyable puissance de feu ou à
l'effet de souffle d énormes au but il
avec une précision diabolique
à l'intérieur des terres sur les côtes
par les lourds canon des navires de
guerre qui croisait au large de la
normandie
avec des calibres alors jusqu'à 400 mm
l'effet d'un de ces obus touchant le sol
à côté d'un panthères été capable de
soulever et de retourner ses 45 tonnes
les mouvements des blindés allemands
étaient souvent la cible de tels tirs
avec les mêmes résultats
combattre dans le bocage normand était à
l'opposé des conditions pour lesquelles
le panthère avait été conçu la
difficulté de faire mouvement le jour
enfui des blockhaus mobile dans de
telles circonstances la poudre sans
fumée la très faible flamme de départ
rendait le panthères très difficiles à
repérer par les colonnes alliés lors des
combats normandie la plupart des images
montrent les panthères fortement
camouflet des branchages dur est resté
invisible n'était rien de moins qu'une
question de survie pour tous les pontes
0 normandie
non
alors que les forces alliées étaient
usés par les opérations de leur mandat
le ministère de la propagande allemand
ne trouva rien de mieux que de faire la
comparaison entre un panther et un char
alliés bien que celui ci fut que m 3
lits qui n'était plus en service depuis
longtemps en europe
naturellement le film relève lames
larges supérioté du panthères
on peux seulement supposer que le
ministre voyant ce film s'est dit que
les familles allemandes dormirait sur
leurs deux oreilles
confiante de là vient du reich
convaincus que leur armée posséder les
meilleures armes
les vétérans allemand de la campagne en
normandie se rappelle toujours de
l'horreur des opérations terrestres vécu
sur les bombardements alliés en
particulier le tycoon de la raf qui
emportait des rockets de 60 livres dans
la puissance de feu pouvaient détruire
inventaire
bien qu'un seul bataillant de yack
panthère et ça vient leur monde où il
fit une curieuse impression
conçu comme un chasseur de chars
construits sur le châssis du pont terre
l'oeil arpentait remportait une version
modifiée du canon antichar p aka 43 qui
équipe également le tigre 2
le pea 4,43 de 88 mm étaient en service
dans la wehrmacht depuis dear 143 malgré
son poids son calibre et son
encombrement sa vitesse initiale très
élevé lui permettait d'être n'importe
quel char soviétique ou alliée à une
distance de 3000 m le compartiment de
combat d'hui à panthère avait été conçu
en réhaussant les plaques latérales et
le dessus de caisse des panthères seuls
3 192 exemplaires furent produits au
total la production n'ayant jamais pu
répondre à la demande
les images de ce véhicule sont très
rares le yak panthères vu ici est filmée
à yoda en 45
ce diamant terres abandonnées auquel il
manque les chenilles étaient embusqués
avec deux autres au passage d'une
colonne de churchill appartenant la
sixième voire death tank brigade le 30
juin en normandie
en l'espace de quelques minutes dix
chars schyle furent détruits dans la
bataille les charrs anglais détruire
deux chasseurs de chars allemands
bien que leur résistance allemande reste
à coria jusqu'en juillet en août la
percée des américains dans la péninsule
du cotentin et la vente de la troisième
armée de patton sur les arrières des
allemands normandie à lons et
l'encerclement des forces allemandes par
l'ouest
alors que les britanniques se battait au
sud jusqu'à falaise face à une heure
résistance allemande désespérer les
américains prenaient la ville d'argentan
elle thonaille alliés ne prit pas
falaise avant le 18 août et entre temps
les trouve également été retiré en
nombre mais la plus grosse partie de
l'équipement avait été abandonné sur
place
les allemands pris au piège dans la
poche de falaise subir des feux nourris
de l'artillerie lourde et britannique
des canadiens des polonais situé au nord
de l'encerclement
au sud les américains lancèrent leur
propre bombardements lourds des
allemands malgré tout continuer à
résister vaillamment la destruction de
la pochette est en marche alors que les
chasseurs bombardiers britanniques et
américains pilonné à coups de roquettes
et panthère les camions et carrioles à
chevaux qui étaient à l'arrêt les uns
derrière les autres sur les routes
menant à falaise
très peu de panthère survécurent à la
destruction et leurs carcasses abandonné
et noirci et fumante fut filmée par un
cameraman alliés après la reddition des
forces allemandes encore présente dans
la poche
mes troupes qui réussira à s'échapper de
falaise et est maintenant en train de
foncer à la scène à la recherche des
ponts les véhicules lourds passer par
des chemins étroits sous les
bombardements incessants des avions
alliés
quelques pente est raide et yack
panthères du bataillon 64 s'étaient
échappés de falaise mais une fois arrivé
sur les rives ils découvrirent que les
chasseurs bombardiers alliés avaient
déjà détruit tous les ponts capable de
supporter leur foi
les blindés allemands étaient ainsi
bloqués seuls quelques véhicules légers
plus emprunter les bacs ou les pompes
fortune construirait m'a vite dans ces
conditions les équipages dire d'autre
choix que de détruire leurs machines ce
n'est seulement que vers la fin de la
guerre que le panthère en action de 28
matches habituel des informations cela
reflète le nombre croissant de panthère
en service une marque de la fin du tigre
1 est un signe du très petit nombre de
kooning tiger en service dans les
bataillons de chars lourds
ces unités était l'objet de toutes les
attentions de la part du département de
la propagande du fait de la volonté de
les présenter au public allemand comme
des unités d'élite c'est pantera
appartiennent aux 60 chars du hermann
goering power corp
filmée au combat entre 15 octobre et le
4 novembre 44
lorsque l'armée rouge lance à son
invasion de la prusse orientale par un
raid entre les villes de gumby naines et
gold ap
la riposte allemande consiste en une
contre attaques concentriques pour
verrouiller la retrait des soviétiques
tandis que le hermann goering cops et le
39e panzer korps avancées sur les flancs
de la 11ème armée de la garde comme il
avait la supériorité aérienne
les choucas allemand bombardèrent
l'avancent blindés soviétiques suivi au
sol par les panthères bien qu'il soit
exact que les panthères est infligé de
lourdes pertes aux blindés russes ne
vous gardez à l'esprit que dans un but
de propagande
les équipes de caméras allemandes n'ont
jamais montré de carcasses de chars ni
le corps de soldats allemands après
l'invasion de la roumanie par l'effort
est deuxième et troisième front
ukrainien en août 44 le peu de forces
allemandes encore disponibles opposé une
farouche résistance face au raz-de-marée
de l'armée rouge
la destruction de la sixième armée
allemande ouvrez les plaines de roumagne
et de hongrie aux forces très mobile et
rapide de l'union soviétique
bien que les poussées soviétiques furent
localement freinée par les panthères ses
contre attaques n'auront aucun impact
sur le tableau général
malgré toutes les qualités de leurs
équipages
à la fin de l'automne 44 les panthères
de la 4è panther présent pologne
méridionale se battait en permanence
contre les avancées continuelle de
l'armée rouge
presque tous les reportages de cette
période montrent l'enchaînement des
opérations de repli de regroupement et
de contre attaques limitées dans le but
était de verrouiller chaque percée
locale le chant du cygne du panthère sur
le front de l'est ce sauna lors d'une
série d'attaqués allemande autour du lac
balaton en hongrie entre février et mars
45 les 18 et 19 septembre 1944 des
unités de la 5ème pense qu'ils n'étaient
plus que l'ombre d'elle-même reçurent
l'ordre d'attaquer de prendre lunéville
en moselle pour stopper la vente de la
troisième armée de patin de la frontière
allemande
mais quelques panthères disponible
principalement des modèles g venue de la
112e penseurs brigade une fois l'une est
vite prise attaques de la 4e division
blindée américaine pu stopper et 50
chars détruits
ces images uniques des actualités montre
une version très rare du panther
dépanneurs remorqueurs un encore plus
rare yak panther ce panther j'ai
abandonné montre clairement la plaque
latérale en une pièce caractéristiques
de cette version
ce que l'on ne peut pas voir ici c'est
la plage arrière et l'avant de la caisse
repensée ainsi que la trappe du pilote
remplacé par un périscope le masque du
canadien aussi plus proéminente 3740
exemplaires du modèle g ont été produits
vers la fin de la guerre
bien qu hitler a exprimé son désir de
lancer une offensive majeure dans
l'ouest alors même que ses troupes se
retirer de france c'est seulement
d'octobre que la planification commence
à l'idée de manoeuvre était de lancer
deux penseurs corp sur les ardennes mal
défendu de traverser la meuse puis de
foncer sur anvers pour séparer les
forces américaines en france des anglo
canadiens dans les polders selon hitler
selon hrw or si les ailiers fuir le
continent
les nouveaux panthères seraient
attribués en priorité aux unités
participent à cette offensive
le 15 décembre veille de l'offensive 400
panther et est disponible sur les 1200
ch a recensé participent à l'opération
peu après le début de l'offensive qui on
avait donné prosaïquement le nom de
poussière d'automne mais passer à la
postérité en tant que bataille des
ardennes
les cinquièmes pas un de ces rares mais
la sixième est sponsor armée gagnaire
chacune du ter en prenant les ali par
surprise mais cette progression
s'arrêter rapidement devant les
difficultés posées par les routes
étroites et gelé le brouillard et des
pages chutes de neige ainsi que la
résistance croissante dès américains
le 24 décembre la 5ème armée aussi à
progresser vers le sud
mais toute avancée vers l'ouest est
bloqué à bastogne par une défense
américaine tenace qui refusait de se
rendre
le 26 une colonne du troisième quart
américain va relever les troupes
positionnées à bastogne vendront stadt
voulait déjà annulé l'offensive mittler
l'interdît le 28
l'initiative allemande s'essouffla les
chars étaient à court de carburant et
surtt abandonner l'un campagne boisé des
ardennes l'opportunité de se camoufler
rendez facile l'embuscade de chat ce que
firent de nombreux tankiste et autres
chasseurs de chars américains
ce n'était pas le meilleur environnement
pour le panther qui ne pouvait tirer
profit de sa précision à longue portée
sous la pression des britanniques et des
américains les panthères survivants
bâtir en retraite
bien que le panthères fut le meilleur
char moyen de la bataille il ne fait pas
disponibles en nombre suffisant pour
contrer efficacement les blindés alliés
les pertes alliées se chiffrer à
quelques milliers de chiens et autres
véhicules détruits ce qui représente à
peine 10 % des moulins dans l'allier
prison d'europe
à ce moment là
au début du mois de janvier avec
l'amélioration de la météo les attaques
des chasseurs bombardiers alliés
reprirent de la vigueur et les pertes
des panthères augmentèrent à la fin de
l'offensive près de 200 panthères était
perdu quelque en était la raison
le total des pertes allemandes dans la
bataille des ardennes s'est élevée à
environ 600 chars ce pantin j'ai modèles
de fin de série reconnaissables au
masque du canon et aux échappements sûr
elle va l'arrière a été détruit à auto
en belgique par les forces américaines
le 26 décembre 1944 contrairement aux
précédents panther qui portait un
camouflage
l'équipage de ce pan torje a tenté de
blanchir le véhicule pour mieux le
camoufler dans la neige linteau a noirci
suggère que le cheikh a subi un violent
incendie interne il été détruits par
l'arrière par un chasseur de chars
américains
le feu ayant été suffisamment fort pour
tordre les barres de torsion brisant
ainsi la suspension
l'incendié a noirci le reste du char
l'avant sa vie en allemagne en 1945 n'a
que rarement rencontré de résistance
significative de la part des allemands
avec l'encerclement dans la poche de la
ruhr de la cinquième porte leur armée de
la 5ème armée et des dix neuf divisions
du groupe plombé très peu de pente et
maintenant encore disponibles pour
offrir une résistance digne de ce nom
plus tard deux petits groupements fait
rencontrées par les alliés équipé d'un
ou deux panthères d'un tigre survivants
d'un automoteurs mise en oeuvre par des
soldats aguerris ils allaient offrir une
résistance acharnée jusqu'à leur
destruction ou à l'épuisement de leurs
carburants et de leurs munitions d'autre
matériel abandonné gens chez les routes
elle se panther j'ai examiné par un
groupe de soldats américains
l'équipage avait clairement essayé de
cacher son char aux chasseurs
bombardiers alliés qui frappait les tête
de colonne volant en rase mottes et
tirant sur tout ce qui semblait menaçant
ici un des derniers modèles de yack
panther construit sur le châssis du
panthères j'ai détruit par un chasseur
de chars n 36 américain len 36 avec un
canon de 90 mm et est l'un des seuls
véhicules allié capable de percer le
blindage frontale du panthère et du yak
panthères l'une des variantes très rare
du panthères rencontrées par les alliés
est un panther j'ai 2 fin de série
équipé de roues en acier dérivé du tibre
2 le feu a aussi détruit les barres de
torsion ce qui a provoqué l'abaissement
de l'ariège
ces images de panthère aux combats près
de brésil ont été prises au moment où
goebbels lui fermer les cinémas et
stopper les journaux d'actualité
habdomadaire en mars 1945
tous sont des modèles g de fins de
séries recouvert d'un camouflage
inhabituelle à pied par des grenadiers
et des semis chenni army de tri tube de
30000 email les panthères sont prêts à
engager les blindés soviétiques y arrive
un char soviétique probablement été 34
85 a été attaquée détruit à très courte
portée
l'offensive finale des soviétiques pour
prendre berlin débute avant l'aube lé 16
avril 945 à un tir de barrage
d'artillerie de 8000 cube et
lance-roquettes multi
ils étaient dirigés vers les positions
allemandes depuis les hauteurs et
commandée par un général russe jordi
joukov plus de succès au rival le
maréchal von cognait lancer sa propre
offensive avec le premier en d'ukraine
1h15 plus tard
trois jours durant les troubles allemand
de résister aux forces du joug kof
les canons de 88 et les unités des chars
équipés de pente et avec que ni staier
détruira grand nombre de chars
soviétiques lire ios de l'oder devant un
véritable cimetière de blindés solide
shokof qui tue au vif par les remarques
de staline concernant le retard dans le
planning de son offensive face à un
savon à ses généraux et demande à une
offensive à tout prix dans l'après midi
du 19 les auteurs furent bombardés les
allemands chasser l'avant sur berlin
commencé pour de bon dans les airs
l'armée de l'air soviétique harceler les
troupes allemandes qui se retiraient du
front de l'est pour leur couper la route
vers berlin
le 25 avril berlin qui est complètement
encerclé un petit nombre de panthère et
d'autres chars rester dans la ville pour
résister à l'avancée soviétique alors
que ceux-ci manoeuvrait guichard moyens
lourds tels lequel 34 et le js2 appuyé
par les canons d'assaut issue 122 et 105
en août le 30 avril la 150e diligent
soviétique s'était frayé un chemin
jusqu'aux rails stade qui était défendu
par les derniers fanatiques ss assistés
par les jeunesses hitlériennes
à 22h50 un petit groupe de soldats
soviétiques mentaliser skalli jusqu'au
toit du reichstag et issa son drapeau
symbole de la victoire de l'urss sur
l'allemagne neige
hitler se suicida et le 2 mai les
soldats allemands encore présents dans
la ville se rendirent berlin était tombé
non
m
il
que nous
oh
il
non
et
nous
tous
m
oh
je
non